gang the merch drop is live baby
alive we're not talking about
Frankenberry either we're talking about
Tony's goodies pick yourself up a date
yeah again go to Ru garbage.com the full
merch store we got all tickets to the
live shows over there we're talking
Tampa we're talking Dania Beach we're
talking Raleigh we're talking Cleveland
we're talking Columbus and we're also
talking Louisville plus we got t-shirts
and lighters check it out gang yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the girl to
be classy after just a big old piece of
trash trash I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at Toadies in the new
edition baby uh-huh her rise continues
she's doing all right she's dating a
higher uh higher tax bracket these days
oh yeah yeah
she's over there on the Tinder huh okay
keeping it real all right my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he's an
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world and I
love him give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan everybody what up gang thanks for
tuning in uh as always please make sure
you rate you subscribe on iTunes full
video of album YouTube as you know those
numbers are
and then obviously the greatest website
of all time
www.patreon.com
over there you get weekly episodes of
hard feelings weekly bonus episodes of
ayg it's a good time check it the F out
yeah what's that number two website out
there
www.ru garbage.com baby T-Bone hit me
merch drop available right now Sunday
night 7 P.M as this is rolling out hit
pause pop open another browser
www.ayg score some teas get some T's we
got [__] Zippos not brand name but
Zippo style lighters
the hippos were too expensive
you know how much it costs to buy a
Zippo put ayg on it then send it to
somebody it's about eighty dollars
selling a couple of zombies there's no
holy crap we should be selling crackhead
lighters at least you like that outside
first go around keep that away from the
kids will you and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer X Jordan here
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones Works to twos the threes
and the fours he crosses the t's and he
dots the eyes and now you can get a
little peek at him ladies over there in
a Toby can give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody hey
what up dude I would have gone with
hippo lighters but what are you gonna do
you know what we're good to Jeep
memories isn't it there was a D in front
of it no we always said the Jeep no I
don't know it they were the big heavy
bulky guys would they have the butane no
they were they were like I remember when
those things happened
[__] roasting some beasters with a
[__] but a few tail lighters were
only good until they ran out of butane
yeah who the [__] we had it but we
dude my parents used I used to have gun
lighters I would buy on the Wildwood
Boardwalk it was called like the double
horse or some something cocked but it
was like an actual [__] handgun hey
[__] and I had another one called the
sailfish which was a revolver that would
spin I could hold up a liquor store yeah
look it back it's like no wonder I'm
addicted to Bernie's now Ma what are you
doing I'm [__] playing with cool
lighters as a kid shout out to it man I
wanted to ask you boys this uh-huh
um are you garbage.com merch drop are
you garbage.com merch drop a lot of cool
tees over there you could check out yeah
baby we got it all going on over there
what's your guys uh stance or what's
your move when you get out of the shower
all right
okay what do you do with the towel
where's the towel go to dry
uh it depends usually on the back of my
closet door if I'm being honest with you
I feel if yeah we just have the hooks in
the bathroom and it's too
together you need you need I would say
the back of the doors that way too the
other gentleman's move I think is over
the door
on the corner of the door that's what I
do on my closet door yeah yeah over the
door so you get real surface area so it
dries out because I gotta be honest with
you I use it hey mine smells like a
homeless guy it ain't good man it's just
that wet it's wet and then I [__] man
it's a tough look but I get I get heat
at the house from the bird about hanging
on the door supposed to go she says put
it over the uh
bathroom or what's it called the shower
I don't like that or anything
yeah no because then the curtain's got
to be open
why no I just put it over the curtain
that's disgusting why because the mildew
and mold to get on those curtains huh
that's disgusting yeah I've taken some
heat keeping that on the door what do
you put yours Tebow corner of the door
yeah corner of the doors the general I
wonder if rich people do that that way I
can get real frustrated when I try to
close it yeah oh also but if you're a
little paranoid Pete like me in the
middle of the night that serves as a
little night light if you keep the hall
light on so the bed I don't get you wait
you keep it on the corner door in the
room oh yeah oh that's a ghost that's
far I don't like that oh I'll do that no
bathroom door she likes the door
completely closed which I don't when you
go to sleep yeah she locks it locks it
down in there wait do lock your bedroom
door unlocked but it's closed that's
enough what are you a Frontiers
you locked up never how many lights do
you leave on in your house when you're
sleeping I saw you the other one you
probably sleep with them all on Toby
dude
nightmares can't get you with the lights
in when I woke up in Connecticut and I
woke up at like six or something like
that your light was just blasting I was
getting sunburned from that thing I saw
it coming through under the door I
thought an alien spaceship that was like
contact
probing yet yeah I keep uh I keep the
whole light on so I can CR I can I can
peek a little bit yeah I don't mind that
I'll do that from we have like a real
little one on a shelf that's pretty much
a night light if I'm being honest with
you sure dude shut in the bedroom door
what's going on she does that earplugs
and then a face mask they can get
anybody can get her
I get it she's trying to fight a losing
battle oh my God Kibby and I shared a
wall in Vermont my bed was shaking it
was a log cabin
you gotta get the CPAP bro okay coming
from the guy that just came from the gym
and didn't shower telling me what I
gotta do I'm down on store anymore yeah
you're also got a machine keeping you
alive it's a little different
hahaha
only guy I heard is I don't snore no
more yeah there's a machine you plug in
that has given you infections shout out
to ResMed
the Indian guy that's treating you I am
ResMed ah man
um yes uh I have something before we I
went out to uh goddamn Family episode
here we haven't done this in a minute I
know well we had the new studio
everybody's in town you got to show off
the new edition it's a big roll out kick
rocks it's The Boys Are Back In yeah
this is what you're paying for right
here now back to your regular schedule
program
deleted my number I don't know what to
tell you
what are you gonna say I apologize no I
was out to dinner uh down there in the
night I was down uh last week or so with
the with the bird who went down to
Wildwood New Jersey sure couple two
three days hanging out relaxing soaking
in soaking into pretty scenes I knew
about this right yes but we went to uh
Avalon nice real Monica that's the only
place that has like a nice nicer
restaurant for the folks out there that
don't know down there in South Jersey
you have Wildwood where the plumbers and
ain't nothing wrong with blue collar
guys that get it together and the HVAC
guys all hang out shout out shout out to
the mechanical contract that as you
start moving down the coast a little bit
down there it starts getting a little
ripe with cash yeah a lot of rich people
Avalon would be the uh
I don't like that either by the way what
I don't like when the beach is real long
why you gotta walk well yeah that person
I mean I was with him yesterday we went
to get coffee it was a block away he
said no
burn your tootsies nah it's just scary
down there I don't like it like that I
like to be able to see the boardwalk and
stuff like that smell the funnel cake
I'm talking about it at night during the
day that's great we're going to the
beach at night well one time finger
banging college chicks going to the
beach at night dude that's crazy that
and [__] no they're trying to get my
skinny dip on oh yeah one time me and my
cousin uh chatted up a couple of broads
at Stone Harbor and we were staying in
Avalon or no we were staying I don't
know maybe Sea Isle it was a Make-a-Wish
weekend or something yeah dude we
weren't supposed to be there I don't
know whose house it was but it wasn't my
parents sure we we went to meet these
girls in Stone Harbor what's right
before Avalon
Sea Isle Sea Isle Avalon Stone Harbor so
is it possible I think we just do this
on a patreon episode I think we were in
Sea Isle and we were meeting girls at
the playground in Stone Harbor and we
had to walk all the way how old were
they
oh wait hold on a second
girls like swing sets
I think I was 13 at the time but you are
predicate that
um that was the thing you would go half
your age plus seven
[Laughter]
that was we were kids
as a young teen pre-teen yeah you would
hang out at the basketball courts the
place the pony rides do whatever the
babes
no I know what you mean that was that
was that was the same that was German
spot
some 11 had me a blast they didn't show
up it looked like [__] no way go down
the Jersey Shore do some real toothy
kissing yeah oh I just made my blood run
cold
got a lanyard hanging out here yeah that
was that was it
I wore one of those one year
no the Tommy Hilfiger one they were hot
what was your keys put in my pocket like
it was the last time like a festival
pass no it was the key
gets cool after 11. come by we were
supposed to be chatting up these broads
over at Stone Harbor and they're like
meet us here at 2 A.M and dude we are
[__] full of hormones we waited for
everybody went to sleep there's four
Dudes on a playground with boners in the
middle of the night
you guys got set up too huh you bump
into another [__] group of horn balls
but we had to to avoid the uh the police
we had to go to the beach and [__]
walk I think we walked all the way
through this is the Normandy again [__]
this is crazy storming the beach in
Avalon yeah to strike out I remember
just being real scary and like real real
Rich because it was like the dunes and
stuff like sure going over there broads
weren't there they got your life story
how big fella got chased by the cops on
the way home jammed up
no I did not get stood up having a nice
meal have it yeah nice enough you know
what I mean decent meal uh can I say
this what the food ain't great down here
no it's not like if you're uh like down
and you're not you're not at [__]
Joe's down in Miami we'll play at me in
[__] the Jersey Shore are
significantly different I don't know
what Miami's rich people 24 7. the
Jersey Shore is open [__] 30 days um
30 days a year fresh clam strips
um and the guy next to me it was kind of
a glimpse into it was a pretty empty
restaurant I mean it was [__] April
down the shore you know what I mean a
bunch of off-season bunch of older
people locals local not even like my mom
goes down on the weekends hearing the
girls
now I think locals live there really
yeah sure and property down there she's
a property owner sure I would consider
her a local yeah you also consider a lot
of things that aren't correct so sure
yeah locals especially in the Jersey
Shore there from Tuesday to Thursday I
practically live
staying in a seashell Motel we did that
one time as a kid what we didn't even
stay for a weekend we went we would do
like our vacation that year was like
Tuesday to Thursday at Summers Point not
even on the beach Summer's Point yeah
we're in a Residence Inn I've definitely
told you about that my dad got a deal
something with the Navy oh yeah you did
you're over there in a townhouse again
staying next to businessmen who aren't
even going to the beach that's a tough
vacation I have a thing too this is I
was talking to new guy Luke about this
and let me know uh NGO NGL like anybody
of mine I have a theory
that it's a very tough if you're using
roller bag luggage and not getting on a
plane it is a bad look all right that's
for airport terminal walkways you have
some samples in there yeah you're you
can't be going down the shore up the
mountains or something with roller bags
dragging it through the sand like a jerk
off you have to get on a plane yeah of
course yeah yeah I did I took my I took
my roller down and I'm like I felt felt
disgusting but if you were going if you
were like a hooker
now get in there and clean yourself up
wipe myself down
putting powder under your arms
um yeah you'd use a duffel for a duffel
but if you're staying for a while I mean
dude when I was a kid we would show up
with everything but the stove sure bags
of stuff yeah we had uh I mean we always
had soccer bags that we would use like
you know those big equipment ones yeah I
mean they weren't like hockey back it
wasn't [__]
the Gang Box
I always wonder what was in there man
getting getting your hands on an open
one of those that'll change that'll if
your brother's playing and you would
like if there was always a pile of dirt
behind the backstop that literally
ramped your bike off
it was always that clay looking dirt it
was that like a red tinge to it yeah
yeah and they're digging that for a
little while bury a couple of gags doing
Avalanche or something let's start
waterboarding Cobra
um but uh so I'm in this I'm in this
gosh darn restaurant and uh
older couple across from us kind of
empty you know what I mean we did go
early we went at like 4 P.M or something
nice it's nice uh it was an older couple
he kind of looked like me she kind of
looked like my what you know what I mean
it was a very like it was very
character-esque you know if they were
casting in a movie in 30 years it would
have been us
and uh he's sitting there he's annoyed
with her like he's not having it you
know what I mean and then sure I'm
listening
he pulls
they do we get there they're eating
their appetite they're entrees so they
had to get there at like 2 15 or
something because the service was slow
so I don't know what time they got there
man and uh but an old guy doesn't like
the restaurant he lets everybody know
about it he pulls out at the table open
air toothpick no the [__] flosser
sticks and he
you could hear them sucking the air
through his teeth after he cleaned it
out getting that third corset and then
they come over they're like would you
like any dessert and he's [__] still
I brought my own
yeah I got I got half a prime rib in the
back tooth
yeah and I'm like oh man that's that's
another level of
dirt bagginess you pop your excuse I'm
not saying you don't do it you do it
when you get in the car you do it excuse
yourself that's why they have the
toothpicks when you walk off yeah you
can't get up get a toothpick and go sit
back down
so Here Comes Here Comes Mr thirsty
trying to eat my creme brulee this guy's
getting a cleaning done
she's carrying out to take X-rays
he's got this thing on yeah I was like
I'm like how's he busting her balls
about I couldn't tell that it didn't
look like a happy marriage if we're
being honest it looked a little
miserable something about the wine
he wasn't happy he wasn't having it I
don't know what it was I can't expect a
nice wine selection down there I don't
think uh well it's BYOB oh so I popped
out ran over got a bottle did you yeah
bottle of wine uh-huh usually don't
drink wine a bottle of Fireball
two chilled shot glasses please
no I don't drink wine but I feel like a
dirt bag rolling with a six or a [__]
perhaps bbr
so I gotta [__] meet in the middle
because
the champagne thing ice and Bam that'd
be all right though yeah
fireball's like a liqueur I've said this
many times good stuff man thick and it's
sweet it's a digest teeth yeah okay
Cinnamon's good for you too I don't
think it's real cinnamon
and now more fresh cinnamon a couple of
pieces of big red in there yeah it's
just big red and [__] Hooch
um
but I I was another thing I didn't know
how to pick out wine obviously I'm an
idiot and I did it just to fit in which
I wish I had wait at the wine store at
the liquor store yeah yeah
I just ran over and just picked I could
tell you right now real simple I don't
remember okay that's the thing I could
Google it as well but it's like I know
everybody says if you spend over like 15
anything over 15 bucks is like all right
yeah no you don't you get I don't I just
throw a bottle yeah when I was 12 I just
didn't want to embarrass myself and roll
in with like Boone's Farm or something
what were you having we eating fish got
a jug of Carlo Rossi
just bring your own bag or whatever you
do
God that's cooking wine
yikes I've seen the dishwashers go with
that a couple of times really jam up the
night snake Flames out
oh man Miguel's hemmed up in the back
um I just picked the 18 bottle of wine
do you know what remember what it was
was it a Pinot was it a mailbox it was a
blend
okay
well what do you want from me always go
Pinot Noir if you if you're not sure
because it's good that was the blend
it's all the same [__]
what do you mean it did the job
I had to drive home with one eye closet
I'm kidding
do you think the golf cart over there no
no I'm physical [__] 35 minute drive
in a car that'd be [__] six weeks and
the golf cart freezing my balls old
that's where that [__] baby
Expressway go around hold it up the easy
best that's a low power vehicle right
there wow uh is that yours or do your
cousin has one right no we have one you
got one proper yeah it was a big tax
break thing if you get it you know like
a golf cart cost two three grand wow I
mean yeah if like if you're going to
play putt-putt yeah that that's a
vehicle that's Street Leagues really I
think they're like eight grand or
something I can't take that on the
highway we do good in Asian manufactured
one so it was a little cheap I think if
you go American and heavy bike they're
about 10 I think we got it for about
five and a quarter got the sun young
Moon zipping around yeah T-Bone what's
like a Street Legal golf cart you poking
around over there yeah like 10-7 well oh
this wasn't 10-7
there's something wrong with the battery
I know that it can't be plugged in for
that long
otherwise the whole house is going to go
up
well we got a chintzy one I do know that
because we never you know they never buy
anything good and right they always got
a [__] cook corn of course it's the
way it's done my family looks at someone
goes oh that's this one's this one's a
thousand dollars and this one's 500 just
get the 500 when I go there but there is
a difference yeah the only thing good
that my parents ever bought like that
was a Traeger we had that for like 20
years I didn't know they were banging
for that long I've only recently heard
of them my dad must have found that when
they started making them or something he
knew about it it's pre-911. that's all
he wouldn't shut up about it yeah and we
at least we just threw that out
wait until he passed then it didn't work
for like five years okay he kept saying
he was gonna fix it oh no nothing's ever
been fixed in my house
okay let's talk about Factor baby
T-Bone says hunger is no longer a factor
yeah copyright to the LLC
gang we love Factor meals over here
there's no secret just had an order
delivered right that I asked Kippy just
got some delivered we're all set ready
to go I love it baby it's fantastic it
takes the thinking because if if I have
too much time ago what do I want to end
up getting pizza but if I gotta Factor
at the house I go hey I'm eating in two
three minutes on a skillet real nice
shout out to the shredded taco bowl love
ya mean it those boys know their way
around a zoodle man they got over 34
Chef prepared dietitian approved weekly
options there's always something new to
try you can rest assured that no matter
what they got you locked up they're
great they're fantastic they got your
back you can even add on delicious snack
options beverage like cold pressed
juices shakes and smoothies had to
factor75.com garbage 40 and use the code
garbage 40 to get 40 off your first box
ashimachi and okay that that's got
that's code garbage 40 at factor75.com
garbage 40 and get 40 off your first box
be like us do it we love it okay let's
talk about Aura Aura frames baby let's
talk about the fact that we all take a
billion pictures and we never ever ever
ever ever look at them yep but you know
how you can and no yeah it could be a
real smash hit for mother's day which is
coming up yeah set the old bird up with
an aura she throws it on the counter you
got the free app you upload the images
then she could see what the grandkids
with the niece and nephew what
everybody's doing a couple of tasteful
nudes we got one in the house so we can
keep an eye on what's going on over
there in Hawaii and we love it yeah it's
fantastic they actually just sent me two
more and never told you I gave them to
my mom I give my mom I was just
spreading them around spread them around
gotta give it a bird keep the birds
happy uh the interactive touch bar
allows you to like photos
congratulations change images anytime
the gifts you make the gifts you make
mean the most so this year turn your
family's past into the perfect Mother's
Day present with connected frame from
Aura name the best digital photo by wire
cutter uh the strategist and featured in
hundreds of gift guides Aura frames are
guaranteed to make Mom or Grandma's
smile sure right now Aura has a great
deal for Mother's Day listeners can
visit auraframes.com and get up to 30
off on their best selling Carver frames
that's Aura
a-u-r-a-frames.com plus listeners get
free shipping with code garbage at check
out this deal ends on May 14th so don't
wait terms and conditions apply that in
the pool my mom's just talking about
redoing the kitchen that hasn't been
finished since the last renovation is
still missing Outlets outlet covers in a
couple places just put the toaster all
the disposal starts going yeah it's all
jammed up over there all right uh but
Gang This is a family episode as you
know when uh you join the old
patreon.com over there we will answer
your garbage question on the air it's
just the best way to know people ain't
mad at them but patreon gets first crack
at a baby because they're the shout out
to the homies this one's from James ten
dollar homie there you go there's a
garbage or take a family member to a
school dance my brother took our smoke
show of a cousin to his senior prom
which Reggie was talking about that
Reggie Conquest took his sister I think
or he went with his sister or something
uh that's crazy that's nuts to me but
you do want it no matter what I'm
looking to close you do want to take the
hot cousin right I mean that was the
whole what's the whole point of it not
with your cousin I'm just saying but my
thing is if you're going to take a
cousin don't take the Yogo [__] swing
oh yes you know try to hit it out of the
park
go with the hot one
because if you if you put a gun to
everybody's head and was like Hey you
have to go to your senior prom with a
cousin everybody's got some when they're
picking everybody's got hot guys I'm
taking Dennis
soccer player that's Quinn shout out to
Quinny uh yeah man that's a tough look
yeah but here's the thing
if you have an older hot cousin all
right I'm listening and you can't get
anybody to go to the prom with you they
don't know her
you show up with that dying piece nobody
needs to know that your family it's
gonna get out you think where'd you meet
how you got it that's those background
stories have to be Iron tight would you
meet her yeah where did you buy
christening
it's my goddamn godmother
uh no yeah but that could give you some
uh if you had a kid would I be the
Godfather by the way no really no okay
why I don't know I don't know now you're
gonna be in your head for the next 40
[__] minutes thanks a lot big guy
what about you T-Bone what uncle Hank
what are you crazy uncle Hank maybe
this is the fat guy I work with
call me Mr Foley my dad's right you are
a fat ass
holy [__] dad he's bigger than you said
uh no I'd have to be my dad says you're
not allowed to have the snacks either
you gotta go blood I'm drinking the holy
water
you gotta go would I be your firstborn's
godfather
um
baby no you gotta go your brother that's
like best man
am I my am I my niece and nephews
Godfather are you somebody's Godfather
yeah yeah me too I'm my nephews I think
I don't know who got the little one
somebody but no you look at I thought
that was based on who would be able to
take care of them if God forbid
something happened no that's what it was
in like the 1800s well there would still
probably be you
my brother's got his hands all over
there oh dude talk about the ultimate
Foley move you get you have a kid die
and I gotta I gotta raise I gotta raise
a little [__] you asking me dumb
questions all the time taking a crack at
your wife
oh God that's gonna happen so I have to
say no you have to say yes what do you
mean no I don't my dying wish you can
leave the kid in the front definitely
I'm definitely not saying yes if you're
actually dying
I think I'm out of town that week he's
gonna go check the meter zip it away in
the golf cart God damn it won't start
your goddamn cheap batteries yeah I
guess you do go family you gotta go
family yeah uh and now it's more of just
maybe your brother wait wait you get my
brother
you that's what I'm saying you didn't
ask Danny it does well okay sorry kid's
all right oh man you're a leech
for the whole lot of you are all [__]
leech I want him to go to private school
by the way
so that's what I always wanted
an Ivy League school no scholarships I
think Paul O'Neill hitting three home
runs yeah but you tell them three four
um that's a deep cut
um
but now it's you just have to because I
got it I gotta I gotta do it with the
priest when I had to do it when I did my
my when I was my nephew's Godfather
that's always good yeah this guy's
running his [__] Yap like I don't
know like I ain't like I ain't got a
newspaper what are you up to on the
weekends hey you want to start poking
Eskimo I wasn't in church where were you
what were you doing
[__] breaking my stones
just the [__] balls let's see what a
nightclub
don't act like you weren't at the Boom
Boom Room all right all right father
um so wait hold on what's the beef you
got in there with him I didn't know
about this he was like when were you
with church last
and I was like what the [__] does that
got to do with the price it'd be in
China right now pal I'm trying to have
you sign off on his document that says
I'm gonna beat his kids Godfather hey I
keep them laced in Nikes as of now just
[__] just sign off yeah there's [__]
um which was a good feeling I [__] it
was just all their birthdays so I laced
them in [__] Jordans nice
[__] real tight hey you want that
boom it'll go uh freebies where'd you
get them dude I bought these
um and uh but shout out to uh sneaker
suplex yeah yeah South Street
um
they were they did the teacher said
something of like these it the word of
how cool the shoes were made it to a
teacher and then back to my sister
really yeah holy [__] they go public
school private school Catholic school
public okay uh yes all right you're
impressing Public School teachers that's
hard Catholics one thing or private
school yeah that's pretty sweet
um
couple of sneaks on the kids yeah I got
up the I've been a little
kids are due for a round of something
what was the last thing you bought them
uh hey will you be my godfather
that's my six-year-old niece
uh Christmas I think
that was six months ago no when I said
when my dad's headstone came in I saw
him we went out to dinner uh that day I
each got broken off of Handy straighten
them out a little bit I'll see him soon
see him around Mother's Day break them
off something a very fully story ask him
for 50 back yeah and taxes
I'm jammed up over here
talking about
I got them sneakers uh I can't remember
it was before Christmas I didn't get
them to Jordans though
because you got no style I'm scared he
was gonna get robbed for them or
something like that what I don't know
runs in a dangerous crowd well I mean
still live in the suburbs of Philly it's
not the [__] it's not the 90s people
are getting people aren't getting robbed
for Jordans
also that might toughen them up a bit
you have to fight for repair for a
[__] fresh set of whites trying to
get your left 91 back
uh all right let's see next question
here this one's from Blake is it garbage
to go to Target to give yourself a
sprayer ax body spray to get the smell
of heaters off yet
I [__] respect that I don't know
about that but if I it's Clay that's
smart I wouldn't say it's classy not an
ax if you're perusing through a
legitimate
department store Target ain't legitimate
not in the wood not we're not where
you're buying cologne or spray
yeah he's not buying it he's [__]
He's jammed up I was I was jamming
smells like an ashtray his wife might
yell at him he might have a hot date
something he's got a [__]
sure I I was I mean I think you've done
this as well when we were jammed up back
in the day if I had like an audition I'd
stop at CVS and hit a little bit of
hairspray I saw that one up a little bit
yeah I've seen that before for sure yeah
just a spritzer too well getting some
goop in your hair yeah what I was gonna
say is if if I'm I would brush my teeth
if I'm in a Macy's
I'm definitely stopping by the cologne
for a little Spritz see what's going on
yeah that's different though this guy's
you're if you're saying if you're in a
Macy's yes he's going I'm going I'm
going I'm going to Target to freshen up
Jesus which tough luck you're smart you
got to be [__] you got to stay on your
toes out there I used to do that in high
school I'd go to the Publix right by my
parents house get the blunt off me yeah
you had to do something
dryer sheets take that sticky
like shaking a tail
I hate the way ax smells that powdery
smell I mean we were in high school when
it dropped and that marketing campaign
had a bunch of [__] tens chasing the
guy who sprayed it on him that Jim
locker room yeah sophomore year junior
year I carry don't play the match that
smell of high school Bo and ax body
spray
yikes I was [__] it was rough we're
using your car back in my days before
all that for all that body spray [__]
dropped yeah old school
couple of those
clean as a whistle oh man imagine the
[__] stench coming off of you
[__] Cheetos we used to shower after
Jim we didn't have to oh why'd you stop
also you didn't shower after the gym
today this is full circle
there's no chicks in here
put some broads in here I'll come in
fresh still for some reason it's for
somehow you even made that the Glory
Days I used to shower after the gym back
in high school I had it all I would even
shower I think we did maybe in seventh
and eighth grade talk about living in
the glory seventh and eighth grade like
the kids were still showering after gym
class but yeah I don't think we did it
in high school we didn't shower at all
we also didn't have to swim and that was
like the big thing you'd have to get in
the pool yeah oh yeah a little [__]
in your banana hammock we used to I used
to love that we had a nice indoor pool
go over to the Middle School hop in swim
around a little bit it was nice
that seems [__] bananas to me they
can't still be doing that there's no way
do they still have gym class
they don't clay yeah
they stopped dodgeball when I was in it
and I remember one teacher hard-nosed
[__] olds like if you had to paint a
gym teacher it was this guy he once told
me and I'll never forget he goes you're
in shape if you could go to work go to
school come home eat dinner and go to
bed and I was like all right that's all
I need to hear
that was his gauge at health I said my
man let's get to an episode of Matlock
you're all right that and they were
supposed to teach us there was that and
he was supposed he was our health
teacher so he had to do sex ed and he
was just like I ain't doing they got a
banana in a condom or something and he
was like I ain't doing it I said hey
buddy respect he's smoking
mister
something old not Mr Whitmer Mr Whitman
was our gym teacher in elementary school
we had Mr Smith yeah it was like B.A
barakas get your shirt tails in and your
shoes tied up that's all he said he
didn't have that [__] done with that
whistle blew you were running some laps
baby well already that right now in
elementary school our gym was also the
cafeteria so you'd be playing basketball
and they're cooking sloppy joes at 9am
it's I wanted to puke every [__] day
it sucked
sitting there [__] first of all I got
a [__] belly full of Cinnamon Toast
Crunch and they got [__] red meat
cooking
and he's telling me to jump rope it's
like buddy pick one here man you guys
want to give me 20 minutes so you put
the stroganoff on
still taste my coffee we got a closed
game over here
oh man
that's a tough look I used to love
swimming though okay go over there it'll
be all right
that's good that's good for you
I used to love swimming
especially in the winter it was always
cozy in there love that smell of an
indoor pool too I always yes but I also
used to walk by remember we walked by
the one on 24th Street of course a big
fan of the indoor pool yeah uh smell but
yeah I mean I didn't want to be doing it
you know fat guy tight little Zack on
him [__] running around I bet you got
in the water real quick I got got my
swim jeans
yeah
and they're in a blazer
I bet you got one I don't want to get
sunburned
it's an indoor pool you bald idiot
ah you stink
[Music]
but they they they annexed it when I the
year I moved to high school accident
yeah the year I moved I said talk about
dodging a bullet
no more dodgeball I think they stopped
dodgeball my senior year there was talks
of it or some places were doing it
because it's you know separates the week
from the strong or something like that
I don't know
um all right let's see here another air
uh sent one this is from sheep ten
dollar Homie first time long time is it
garbage you get an air freshener for
your car then say [__] it and hang it in
your apartment instead I don't hate that
what it's trashy yes no
there's something you're one of the
trees you reach it if you walk into an
apartment and somebody's got a tree in
there
they're selling weed
that's drug dealership right there yeah
I mean there's there gets to a certain
point where that you at a certain age
where your brain switch at least the
difference your brain chemistry switches
over and like that fake scent
it smells good when you're young you're
like oh this but like that fake scent in
a house or something sure you gotta go
candle you gotta go potpourri it gets
too [__] fake nowadays we're rocking
this thing now called uh Pura I think
you plug it in it's like a subscription
give that a goog Pura air freshener I
think it's p-u-r something the broad
runs essential oils it ain't bad right
the diffuser with the essential oils
pumping get some lavender some Citrus
those are nice real [__] nice the dog
barks at it it's a whole thing
that was a Glade plug-in man myself yeah
I said I used to wear it as a pager back
in the day okay let's talk about bass
turn up I ain't talking about your
Grandmom's Mitsubishi either all right
you're talking about high class [__]
chair gang if you're tired of having
somebody sit on your luggage so you can
zip it up because your shirts are too
big or whatever you got going on that's
usually might be sounds like a personal
problem base bags are Sleek affordable
so you can travel effortlessly by
looking like a hot shot which is what
life is all about think until you make
it sure ah they thought of everything
you could want in a piece of luggage
check this out they got 360 degree
gliding Wheels a cushion handle a
built-in weight indicator now that's a
[__] dangerous deer clear of that
thing buddy they'll be charging you for
for luggage overages left and right
you're gonna have 80 stickers on you
come out in the oversized luggage
carrier gang they're fantastic they sent
us
um the weekend duffel baggage they got a
little
it's great because I'm a weird guy so I
don't like my dirty shoes around my
clean clothes
and they got you covered baby uh whether
you're packing for a quick getaway or a
long vacation base has just what you
need right now base is offering our
listeners 15 off your first purchase by
visiting basetravel.com garbage go to
base b-e-i-s travel.com slash garbage
for 15 off your first purchase that's
base one more time get a pencil write it
down b-e-i-s travel.com garbage now back
to that gosh back to the show all right
let's see here this one's from Hachi
Macho Man uh is it garbage to use out of
day Pro out of date products like bread
or corn to go fishing with
that was like the first time you went
fishing we used corn yeah corn hot dogs
little corn niblets hot dogs all right
lunch to me we're being honest
however you say we [__] these fish and
get a couple of cans of coke out of here
let the sunnies fend for themselves
they'll do all right trying to get my
lunch on yeah yeah corn corn was big uh
yeah corn and hot dog I mean that's
still uh
because it was hard to get your hands on
[__] nightcrawlers or blood worms you
know what I mean because he had an idea
to get those things we there was I think
I might have mentioned this a year there
was a bait vending machine in my town
like a soda machine but with live bait
you would go put a dollar in and get a
can of [__] worms or whatever Kevin
get out of there I forgot my hand though
trying to get shaking it yeah but that
was great you were in a jam in the
morning you got to go get bait sure go I
think it was Robinson's Bait and Tackle
you know I remember the first time you
handed you you held the fish remember
the like the sunnies they gotta go down
with the spikes spikes yeah God damn
those things were like you know what I'm
talking about you ever went fishing
before
yeah but not I don't know what I think
about spikes
on the scales on the on the back fins of
the fish the back fin that would go off
they're spiky they're spiky so you have
to grab it by the head I can't see you
going fishing and pull like pull it down
so that you know imagine like a
switchblade kind of like you're like
pushing the blade you're pushing the
blade down so it can't fish suck no fish
are pretty sweet yeah fish are sweet
we have a [__] I don't know where it
would fit but I got a Marlin a stuffed
Marlin and I don't know where it would
go though bring it in I don't know where
it would go it's pretty [__] yeah
it's in the shore house yeah bring that
it's pretty [__] sweet we need
something for over by the uh uh [__]
dartboard
that's a bit no it's bigger than that it
would be like one of the biggest things
gonna go up there where up top in the
middle above the picture maybe I like it
it's pretty cool yeah that's real cool
shot I didn't know you had that yeah
bring that in uh scoop that up this
weekend Giggle and Marlin uh
uh all right let's see this is from
Uncle nuts is it trash to use a slice of
bread as a napkin
that's fun especially if you're eating
Italian food I've done it yeah yeah of
course
of course I mean you know essentially
Brett at the end of the pasta dish
you're [__] sure you're busting the
table baby put it all on there you know
what I used to love
bread sure but we'd have spaghetti and
we were so trashy we wouldn't have
sometimes every once in a while we do
like a nice loaf of Italian bread cut it
up whatever that started when I was in
like junior high high school but let me
tell you something a piece of fresh
piece of white bread with some butter on
it make that into a little sandwich and
then give it a little wipe around the
bowl
oh that was yeah that was that was a
good chunk of that we even used
hamburger buns and [__] like that that's
all you got
hey we're in a freezer from Fourth of
July it's now like [__] March mop it
up your rigatoni with a hot dog roll
shout out to it yeah we just I remember
as a kid we used to have we'd have like
a half a loaf of white bread just on a
little plate in the middle of the table
with the butter there
yeah maybe pig is sleepy
looking for night night that's that's
when I used to do margin on a slice of
[__] strowman's king-sized white
bread [__] put you right out I used
to watch my stepdad put it on like
meticulously like it was like icing on a
cake like just [__]
there was always something about the way
dads would prepare their little you know
their their thing just the pepper
everything just made it look really good
classy
yeah pepper real glassy
are you a pepper guy
use pepper is that a real question yeah
I don't know some people don't use pets
sometimes you turn into a cartoon of
yourself
Toby you like salt I've never seen you
use pepper what are you talking about
we've been friends for 10 years I've
never seen you ask for the pepper
grinder I do like a gentleman first of
all we don't eat at places where they
have pepper grinders
what are you talking about we usually
eat up diners and that's about it
a pepper packet lava peppers
Cassidy's old joke yeah
okay insert here
and that was Tom Cassidy folks Tommy C
uh this one's from mope is it garbage if
you invite your two favorite comedians
to your wedding in hopes they politely
decline but send a gift instead
respect the attempts my friend I might
show up to that yeah depending on where
it is
that'd be all right just go get [__]
up at someone's wedding no I'm not gonna
embarrass anybody yes I will embarrass
somebody nah I'd be a gentleman that'd
be nice to be at a wedding
where there's no
attachment or affiliation it's all right
would be nice it's all right when you
have a real loose one you're like I'm
[__] you're just like lying at the
dinner table and stuff
yeah yeah yeah we're just [__] micro
processes making [__] up they don't know
you'll never see this [__] guy again
oh you're just saying [__] like oh
encryption that don't work
I know trust what you need is a VPN
I'm gonna get some more salmon you guys
want anything you guys want a drink
I've no one's ever asked me to a wedding
like that I've never been somebody's
date to a wedding where I didn't know
anybody
huh
Lady Killer
thank you thank you as a force of nature
on the uh on the Dance Floor
uh all right let's see here this one's
from Peter is it garbage you to use the
glass tray in the microwave as a plate
me you are jamming that's always got
something on it that's never cleaning
even when it's a little bit of hot dog
or something in there even when it's
clean it's still oil like yeah it
doesn't it doesn't dry like a plate
something happens in that microwave
moisture really builds up in there yeah
man it's [__] bouncing the atoms it's
like a rainforest or something yeah I
don't [__] with it as much of a
disgusting human being as I am which is
well documented here on this program
yeah I don't like that at all can't do
it I always put a plate in there
I will
set something on top of the
you know the the plastic thing that
everybody has now we've never had one my
mom has one now but we never had one oh
we never had one growing up that was
like a million dollars but now I'll
throw [__] whatever on top of that
thing on top of it yeah just leave I'll
leave that in there when I heat stuff up
and just put it on top you know what I'm
talking about it it looks like a like a
bowl yeah and you're supposed to put
that over sure but why do you put it on
top of it just because I'm lazy Okay
just set it on there okay yeah I thought
you were saying it had some sort of I
just didn't understand now just pure
laziness okay throw a couple diesels on
there keep it moving oh yeah this is a
lot to do this is killing me they crunch
up too
um now you wrap diesels I would wrap you
wrap some hot dogs in a paper towel
that's all right that'll [__] that'll
get you cooking in there too never do
you go hot dog in the bun paper towel
he's cooking the the bun for to come out
like a brick no probably moisten's
probably softens
wait a minute you can't cook the hot dog
in the bun at the same temperature for
the same time
the hot dog's got to be the man's a
doctor he's got a damn PhD okay wait
you're pretty hot dog
you're telling me what you're gonna just
[__] act like I didn't do that are
you [__] kidding me
that's egregious
he's got a pretty hot diesel over there
PhD
not bad
um I'm fascinated by this this doesn't
make sense to me yeah dogs on a brain
yeah that's crazy no probably the
moisture from the hot dog softens up the
bond it all gets nice and cozy no okay
yes I'm telling you that's what happens
the hot dog needs to be cooked for at
least two minutes no what that is a lie
I would put two Oscar Meyer cheese dogs
in sometimes in the bum but not always
just on a paper plate easy minute
done out the door even a regular bun a
minute that's why you have the paper
towel to add a protective layer because
think about it you know when they when
you're like you need to see his research
you get a hot dog in a ball game it goes
in that sleeve that's pretty much
serving as the same thing but that's
right they're cooking that like that no
they're not cool I don't know how
they're cooking but I'm saying that's
retaining the Heat and making the bun
soft that's what the paper towels do
sure sure I got you you know what we can
do now
so we have the addition yeah we can do
the [__]
hot dog how to cook the hot dog the best
hot hot dog taste test oh boil it hot
dog cook off hot dog boil it toaster
microwave
skillet
Skillet Hot Plate yeah get a hot plate
that's happening I'm down that's the
next patreon video we're doing the hot
dog cook-off
the indoor hot dog cook maybe get an
expert in here too a hot dog expert yeah
look at Dan Soder or somebody that likes
a nice hot dog that lives in the
neighborhood there you go
like it
um all right let's see here uh this is
from Brian ever take Adderall before
going to a bar to do bar games such as
darts Big Buck Hunter silver Striker
golden tea
uh he says it's viewed as a
performance-enhancing drug which I do
agree with sure but
hey unless if [__] I assume oh you
thought it doesn't get you I'll allow it
I assume all you kids are on Adderall
I don't touch the stuff that's your
generation I get high on life we had a
ritalin when I was a kid I mean yeah
it's the same [__] they [__] up and
gave me that once
that was a quick weekend [__] close
that close those refills down real quick
yeah that's tough but it's also like
those games are meant to be drank you
know what I mean if you're drinking sure
I get that that I started shooting
better in the big buck thing on patreon
when I had a couple two three two three
beers in me but you're saying if you're
taking the Adderall you're more focused
that might be a detriment sure you're
not even that you're overthinking it
yeah huh this ain't finals yeah hmm
either way you're a dirt boy
but it gives you a steady shot you know
to each their own I I can't judge you
um all right this one's from Eric B
first time long time never have one red
ever smoke Marlboro blacks
no but you know what somebody are they
those short little John's they must be
they look like me not a chip or
something to me I I don't know I don't
know let me I gotta get eyes yeah you're
thinking of Marlboro Menthol no I'm not
gonna be hemmed up I used to smoke those
really menthols
how long did you work at the beauty
pilot well miles was the original and
best
the Marlboro Mild was the navy blue pack
did you and they were something weird
when I met you or was that uh our buddy
John Nunn I think smoked like 62s no he
smoked 27s yeah yeah which I have some
Associates this move uh 27s somebody was
brought up uh this last night
um camel wides do you remember those
yeah oh yeah the 72s the 72 gauge uh
there's always like the hot chicks
always smoke those I don't know why hot
chicks and like pot dealers always had
camel wides I haven't thought about that
in 20 years like smoking a colored
pencil man those things
stunk man I [__] hated those things
um yeah two three drags off of those I'd
be gagging what are Marlboro blacks do
you have a what flavor Marlboro Black is
a variety Special Blend usually cheaper
than regulars yeah Menthol and regular
flavored lighter but Bolder than
original Reds wait there's a little bit
of Menthol in there I guess like a camel
somebody handed me a camel crush the
other night at the bar [__] punched
him in the face only get out of town man
begging for a headache yeah that ain't
great those things stink
um this sounds like it's made up it's
just cliffins yeah it's whatever you
know Marlboro blacks yeah they're just
sweeping up what's on the factory floor
charge them a nickel it's a little bit
of Menthol I don't trust that at all now
sometimes it could be a good twang you
know what I mean a little bit sure like
a dabble do you my buddy had the best
argument for not smoking hundreds he was
like more same price I don't think
that's how they get yeah yeah which I
was always told it was the same amount
of tobacco just not as packed either way
you look weird smoking them my my
grandma my [__] stepmom used to
[__] Marlboro light one undies
heavy bike in the entry in the purple
Intrepid whipping work
playing Bob Seger Greatest Hits
those things hang low
hello yeah heavy they're heavy but it's
like a baseball bat you got a Louisville
Slugger hanging out of here about
[__] busting a huey
uh this one's just from fun this is from
Kevin P riddle me this what if the long
hair is lying
I don't trust them scary lying folks
that's a good time
um all right this one's from Chowder
stash it does a personal attack is it
garbage to tell everyone your Peloton
username than not use a Peloton for the
entire month of March looking at you
Baldi I'm back on it check out other
people can see yeah I'm public baby what
we got a group we're about
maybe a hundred strong hashtag are you
garbage on Peloton check me out I'm King
of the board he is all working out at
the same time yeah everybody comes over
no do you all take a class together
how does that work they all come over we
got my bedroom
um they're all sweaty talk about ax body
spray what
um no you can just track you can you
know I guess I don't know I don't really
communicate with anybody I don't so you
haven't been on the Peloton in a month I
didn't tell you to do it for March while
we were building the studio ah okay I'm
back on it though baby kids back on it I
think I did seven out of the past nine
days there you go that's my d Everybody
how long are you going how long you ride
I do a half hour shout out to Alex
Tucson I do uh 30 minute uh hip-hop
rides and he's telling you to do
different [__] throughout it mm-hmm
cup the balls no yeah hop on the pegs
you guys they control the speed you ever
catch a downhill Coast a little bit no
oh really
try to do a little cruising that's what
they need they need a beach cruiser
model and I'd hop on someone's pegs for
a minute
that's how you're gonna get people on
there places Banking and they no they're
[__] killing it they're doing good
um yeah you change the resistance like
you're like you just all right this is a
[__] do they know if you don't no you
know though sure uh which I'm okay with
you and your girl butcher
that's doing some girl push-ups today oh
Connor walked in I was mid-girl push-ups
he does like an Iron Man got your yoga
pants on oh hey Chris
you got a yoga mat and a smoothie oh hey
Chris man the difference between my
workout and O'Connor's workout is wild
he's like in budge training his doesn't
have cheeseburgers I presume
a little piece of iron but I'm back
shout out to the we got an army of
garbage I think it's just hashtag are
you garbage everybody signs up you check
in you can high five the whole nine
yards all right so I highly recommend it
if you're on there check the kid out
keep me nose is running keep me intact I
keep her keep the you know the what is
it to be honest keep me honest
[Music]
good luck nerds
many have tried
you're just putting Hans on the
bike's numbers kid
it's uh it's all so it comes with cleats
with like a little click it like you
know they're like tap shoes kind of sure
they look like European shoes you know
those shoes all those European guys wear
you're wearing them out but they got a
little thing on and you can't walk you
feel like a real bow so prancing around
in those
it's a tough look
I get all over the airport they're like
reverse high heels the toes are up
because there's something under them oh
really yeah so you're like walking
around yeah I remember uh you know the
Seinfeld episode with those with those
sneakers Jimmy I just watched it yeah my
my brother and his friends had a pair of
them they shared them
oh they thought they were gonna be
dunking nothing
dunking their balls in each other's
mouth
man I remember when those things rolled
on the scene they were in the back of
the garage [__] all looking at them
like yeah this is gonna change the game
good luck shooting underhand
kick rocks
I hope you I hope you have all your leg
strength on the bench
they wore them in school to try to like
strengthen their legs see them coming
down [__] bebopping and scatting
laughs
like that kid that walked on his tippy
toes buddy relax
closing with some broad in her locker
that was big and uh it's coming down the
hallway our version of those would be
soap shoes remember soap shoes soap
shoes had grind plates in them you guys
wore wheelies no Heelys Heelys kids like
that was like five years ago that was
like not that long ago I could have
swore your generation was zipping around
in those things no I mean not mine mine
was yeah that's more tea but there was a
there was a dad in the neighborhood
pushing him heavy and we come to find
out that he got a job Distributing them
so who's trying to just make sales
around the neighborhood
hey Toby we're on the street is you
don't even have a set of Heelys
these chicks will hook up but even get a
set of healies
he hires a bunch of hot rods
see those girls over there yeah tell
them if you had a cool pair of wheelies
you'd be all right
[Music]
um
did you get a pair no never huh but soap
shoes well they were soaps right yeah
they had a grind they were like skate
shoes with like a grind plate in them I
could do what so you could like run and
like grind on like a handrailer that's
pretty cool they were tough to come I
think you had to order them through the
mail and this is like before they
weren't at store yeah you had to put
that you were a virgin in writing yeah
for them to send them to you what did
skateboarders think of those not like
them the lamest thing ever made that's
lame yeah dude okay I thought it was
pretty cool
I mean I was hey Lou canceled that
Amazon order Luke if a box of soaps
comes it ain't for me all right just put
it in my bag
I'll return them at hoodies
I I also I was in fifth grade maybe I
didn't know what cool was sure you know
what I mean but I did my buddy my buddy
Justice what I said I did
your buddy Justin had he had a pair and
we would use them during recess you'd
swap them
what do you mean you would put them on
too yeah
so you would take your shoes off put his
shoes on and then go grind on some rails
sure impress the chicks
I fall off
I always went to flip used to make fun
of me so bad
I would make the same noise every time
selling a female tennis player yeah
there's a lot of that [__] Kippy
Williams over here
all right let's see here uh we'll do two
more and then we gotta [__] Ram it up
there gang uh this one's from Ariana
have you ever done the worm
man let me tell you something
if I could go back I would have loved to
have been one of those guys I didn't
have the abdominal strength to pull that
off you know if you could do the worm
that [__] was [__] cool maybe more in
your time yeah that's what it hit what
do you mean there was a kid that could
do it Jimmy I grew up in the middle of
break dancing and I couldn't break [__]
you're over there eating nightcrawlers
I could do anything man somebody at the
7th or eighth grade dance would [__]
get a circle hit the floor and [__]
knock out a worm God damn yeah that kid
was getting a laid I don't think uh took
me to hold dance to build up the courage
that's somebody to dance and it was a
slow one
I'd have a little Stinger going
been there
can't get too close man did you have
school days I can't imagine what your
school dances were like oh no dance we
did we did play a reform school in
soccer one time they they didn't have
jerseys and they had this one guy who
had to have been 375 pounds massive this
dude and they whooped our ass like seven
to one and they were celebrating after
the game and he went to do a backflip
and it looked like he was he he wasn't
gonna make it like he went like to catch
himself with his hands almost like a
back handspring and I was like oh this
[__] idiot trying to backflip his fat
piece of [__] lands on his hands
backflips into the worm I was like this
is the coolest thing I've ever [__] a
fat guy doing the worm yeah backflip
into the worm crazy
love the worm you couldn't do it right
the worm yeah no no I but I'd imagine
maybe you could I can't even do the
mashed potatoes you could worm and like
move across the floor wait is this one
of Toby's you've done it or you think
you can do it I know I know for a fact I
can you've done it don't not know for a
fact cause yeah you've done it okay yeah
yeah it's not hard I mean yes it is it's
not easy you'll see people doing in the
grocery store it's it's not it was easy
everybody would be moving down the
street as worms what are you talking
about we could all be [__] doing this
[__]
it's hard as [__] there was like one kid
in every three schools that could do it
trying to do it you're just rocking back
and forth like a boat that's what I look
like I can't do the slug pretty good I
try to is that a thing that's why I get
sweaty when I'm laying down
they pour salt on you
ever did it as a kid pour some throw
salt on a slug yeah oh man looking back
I wasn't the snail didn't you you salt
the snail slugs the snails who the [__]
got snails around I think we had snails
we had snail in the shell
yeah I think so really maybe not I don't
know I freaked out if I would have saw
one of those things kept walking I
haven't trusted I don't trust Nails I
don't know why
they got the shell this weird I like a
slug nice rainstorm slug why thy assault
a little bit of hot sauce
hold your nose right down
a couple of slug shooters
all right mine with cocktail sauce uh
all right all right I mean
this one is from Colleen is it garbage
to bring a box fan into a hotel room oh
man that is [__] you shouldn't be
moving those man they belong where they
are that's [__] tough but I do
respect it because it's like a
helicopter in the room dude those things
move units oh man you have to put
something you have to put that up
against something the best thing is if
you can prop it against the floor in the
wall yeah to get up yeah and create an
atmosphere and forget a trade window
I've been woken up in the middle of the
night in a panic when that thing Falls
over oh dude it's like a chopper going
down
[__] that I mean I told you before I had
uh an air conditioner in my old
apartment I had I put cold water
remember that remember this I mean I
didn't have an air conditioner in my
first apartment in the heights I was
living in yeah not with my friend when I
got my own and Nadine was still sure
sure the place used the Airbnb yes yes
and I didn't have it so I filled up the
wall it was like 118 degrees I was on
the sixth floor or fifth floor so
[__] hot I was I'd wake up delirious
like actually delete no ice machine
nothing wake up drinking ice machine I'm
drinking warm water to try to hydrate
couldn't even cool down couldn't even
call my inside how did you put it in the
fridge I don't know man I'm making a lot
of bad decisions back then
and I thought this was going to work I
had a box fan I spent 12 bucks on a box
fan that I probably financed or
something to get it and I felt I filled
the tub up with cold water I think and
then put the put the fan in front of
that thinking it would I don't know if
I've ever heard blow cold the cooler air
on me and it did work a little bit
till the fan fell in the tub and I blew
out the block
[__] [__] torch the grid I was I
was like Enron dude I was shutting down
power grid I gotta deal with the mayor's
office
[__] comptroller got a hold of you
the charges are still pending all right
we gotta wrap it up gang we love you to
death are you garbage.com check out the
merge drop check it out you can grab
your tickies there too that's gonna be
the One-Stop shop for all your ayg needs
that's everything baby we got Ru
garbage.com has all the tickets for the
live shows it's got the merch right now
get it while so applies last that's just
a marketing tool it'll always be
available gang we love you and we'll see
you next week peace